[Music]
we continue here on the guy benson show
we were just mentioning new york and
texas
let's go ahead and talk about florida as
well
because
i think we all know that florida has
been in the spotlight politically
because the governor of florida is seen
as a political threat
hence the relentless
program and project of demonization of
ron desantis
that we have covered and chronicled and
reacted to and fact-checked on this show
over and over again
there's a new one out there that will uh
we'll get to here in just a second but
first i want to draw your attention to a
new poll out of florida
this is from usa today in suffolk
and they asked florida voters about the
upcoming midterm elections
and let's just say that things aren't
looking great for the democrats in the
state of florida
president joe biden has a 39 approval
rating in florida which is about right
we've seen a few national polls having
biden at 39 percent or so and florida is
a large diverse
swing state so it would make sense that
his job approval would be roughly as bad
there may be a little worse than it is
nationally
biden's personal
favorability rating
is underwater by 11 points in the state
of
florida so what about some head-to-heads
looking at 2022 this election cycle
first of all on the senate side marco
rubio is up for re-election this year
and they've put
a woman named val demings up against him
and right now rubio is ahead by eight
points in that race
49-41
maybe it'll tighten like this thing's
going to ebb and flow
but rubio is a very heavy favorite to
win reelection being up by eight
in florida is a pretty significant deal
now on the governor's side
you've got a few democrats who would
like to be the nominee against governor
desantis
you have charlie crist who's the former
governor member of congress he ran for
senate and failed he is this shape
shifter who believes nothing
he has run for statewide office in
florida as a republican
as an independent
and as a democrat
and i think for this race he's got his
magic eight ball and he shook it up what
am i going to be today and it's democrat
so you've got charlie crist means
or believes absolutely
nothing
imagine believing so little
that you run for statewide office
under three different party labels
depending on what you think your
personal ambition might be helped by
at any given moment
it's actually almost impressive
in terms of its
sheer cynicism and selfishness
and he's probably going to get
gerrymandered or redistricted out of
existence in his house seat he's
currently a democrat so now he's going
to run for governor
he trails desantis by six points
in this poll
then you've got nikki freed who is the
current agriculture secretary but she's
just sort of like one of these twitter
trolls she's the one who recently
compared ron desantis to hitler
said desantis reminds her a lot of
hitler
maybe she and whoopi goldberg can go to
remedial history class together or
something
but that's what she said she's
supposedly like the leading serious
candidate on the democrat side
she believes every conspiracy theory she
amplifies every nonsense attack on ron
desantis even stuff that gets instantly
debunked
she was a hype woman for that crazy
person rebecca jones
right the career criminal who's been out
there lying constantly about florida
manipulating the data it's all untrue
it's all been debunked
but because it was being used as a
weapon against desantis nikki freed
recklessly amplified all of it
i don't know if she ever does her day
job has she ever done anything about
agriculture in florida it seems like all
she does is sit on twitter
and lob insults at ron desantis how's
that going for her
in this poll it's desantis 51 nicki
freed 40 desantis up 11.
ron desantis is the only statewide or
national figure in the state of florida
that in this poll is above 50
on favorability rating
he's plus 10 52 42.
and as i said he leads his would-be
democratic opponents by a range of six
to 11 points
so i tell you this not because it's
dis-positive not because polling at this
stage really matters a lot although we
are in the election year
right these are not good signs for the
democrats i read you these polling
numbers mostly just in case there are
any members of the media listening
because i like to give them a sad
because they have tried so hard i know
you guys have tried so
hard
against ron i know
and it has to be really really sad
to see the people of florida not falling
for it sorry
but that's what's happening so far and
it brings me great joy
even as someone who is not necessarily
in every way shape or form
giant ron desantis stan i like him i
think he's done a good job i mostly talk
about him because of the insane attacks
against him
and we'll get to another one here as
i've now teased in just a moment i do
want to say this one thing
before we move on from the usa today
poll out of florida
which as i mentioned has biden at 39
approval
he's at 36 approval on the economy
so it's not going well in fact
it's so ugly out there
that they did a hypothetical poll in
this survey of democrats
if there were looking ahead to 2024 a
primary where hillary clinton where he
brought back crooked h
and they had her run for the nomination
and there was a primary in florida
crooked h would beat joe biden by three
points in a democratic primary for
president right now
based on this survey
that's how bad it is out there
for joe
our esteemed president there's another
2024 poll that's interesting
they polled what if
in florida these are florida voters what
if donald trump ran again
and ron desantis also ran and they were
going head to head which one would you
prefer be the republican nominee for
president and it's pretty close
trump is ahead by single digits
but desantis is is
hanging in right there
and of course he needs to get reelected
first but he could maybe build towards
something bigger
in the state of florida i also find the
head-to-head less interesting than this
and this is the last data point that
i'll share with you from the poll
they asked florida voters again the
largest most diverse swing state in the
country
if in 2024 there was a presidential
election and it was joe biden on the
ballot for the democrats
head-to-head against ron desantis or
head-to-head against donald trump who
would you vote for in a rematch
a 2020 rematch
in 2024 trump versus biden trump leads
biden by three points
47 to 44 percent in florida right now
ron desantis
leads biden by eight points
52 to 44
right now
long way to go
very early stages but i do think that
republican voters need to think about
viability
in 2024
if trump decides to run or if he's
thinking about running is he the best
person to actually have a chance to win
i think republicans have a chance to win
big
potentially in 2024
i think the candidate that would give
them the best chance to do that
is who republican voters ought to be
considering that's a key calculation
moving forward
now it's clear that the democrats in the
media view desantis as a threat not just
in 2022
they're going to try to beat him this
year but based on this and other surveys
that's going to be
a heavy lift
that's not guaranteed that he's going to
win reelection desantis but you know
he's in the driver's seat at this point
what they are really scared about is the
presidential cycle
if this guy can win especially if he
wins kind of big in the state of florida
and he racks up a bunch of victories and
he's the type of candidate that can
bring in an appeal to trumpy republicans
and moderately trumpy republicans and
trump skeptical republicans if he can
sort of coalesce everyone
that's something that they're worried
about and they are not telling us that
with their words they are telling us
that with their actions
attack after smear after lie about ron
desantis from the media and the
democrats working as a team as they so
often do to me it is very telling part
of the reason that i have grown fonder
of ron desantis
who i don't think i've ever even met
is because of the way they attacked him
they attack him and continue to the fear
is palpable they are trying to take him
out and they're doing it with
such silliness and baselessness and
hysteria that it has caught my attention
obviously which is why we talk about it
a lot here on the show
i think that
performance in terms of you know
governance
you could cite for example keeping
florida schools open last year big
decision governance is
a feather in ron desantis cap right now
i would say that if he's able to pull it
out
let's say he has a convincing victory in
florida a crucial state that would be
another feather in his cap
especially if he's weathered the storm
of all of these attacks and then the
attacks themselves
from the left and from the press
and the way that he's responded to them
that to me is another big plus
you know sort of in the in the
positive versus negative column when
assessing ron desantis as a political
actor
now here's the latest thing that they're
going to try to do with him
apparently and it's it's so dumb
apparently there was a group of like
neo-nazi a-hole racists
there were like
11 of them or something
and they went on some overpass in
florida i think somewhere in central
florida they were waving their nazi
flags can you imagine being such a loser
that you wave the flag
of a defeated
disgraced genocidal regime like these
are just extremely pathetic people
representing a disgusting ideology and
there's 11 of them for a reason
that this is
way out there on the fringe so they were
doing some
hateful nonsense on an overpass
people saw it there i guess some flyers
have been distributed at some point and
people were obviously incorrectly upset
about nazis doing nazi things
because i think almost everyone can
agree nazis sort of like along with
like hardcore communists those would be
sort of the epitomes of evil that
inflicted
misery on humanity and killed millions
of people it's just awful
doing anything in the name of that type
of regime to me is
horrendous
and also sort of baffling it's just like
very sad loser people
who are engaged in this stuff
and so
this became a scandal because it
happened in florida and it's like well
why isn't ron desantis out there
denouncing this
so that became the drumbeat ron desantis
won't denounce
nazis
like
are you kidding
i don't think even nicki freed even
though she compares him to hitler i
don't think even nikki freed believes
that ron desantis is interested in like
winking at nazis but this is how
desperate they are so that's what they
said
that's been one of the narratives and
it's been all over you know hashtagging
and left-wing twitter and that whole
echo chamber
and so just to give you a sense of how
mainstream this nonsense has gotten
stephen colbert
who runs his nightly
group therapy for liberals on cbs
on his so-called comedy show last night
he was talking about this
and he made this point in cut 15.
speaking of the worst people in public
office florida governor and man
describing what adele's music means to
him
ron desantis over the weekend
horrifically
there were a couple of nazi rallies in
orlando
i assume they were trying to annex the
sudetenland pavilion at epcot
now this is terrible and the easiest
thing in the world to condemn unless
you're ron desantis who remains silent
okay so he mentions desantis and the new
york liberal crowd at their
therapy session they all boo together
bad boo and then what colbert alleges is
that there have been these nazi rallies
in florida and desantis silent won't say
anything that was yesterday on colbert's
show problem for colbert is not only is
this not comedy and not funny and
totally insipid it's also factually
wrong because the day before on monday
desantis had condemned these people he
called them jackasses
he said they'd be held accountable he
also said he wouldn't play along with
the stupid left-wing game this answer is
part of the reason why i think that he's
a skilled politician and popular on the
right here was desantis the day before
not being silent about this so fact
check there for colbert on his comedy
show
cut 16 this was monday governor desantis
these people
these democrats who were trying to use
this as some type of political issue to
try to smear me as if i had something to
do that were not playing their game you
know some jackasses you know doing this
on the street first of all state law
enforcement is going to hold them
accountable because they were doing
stuff on the overpass so we're so
they're absolutely going to do that and
they should do that
but i'm not going to have
people
try to smear me that belong to a
political party that has elevated
anti-semites to the halls of congress
like ill and omar
that have played ftse with the bds
movement that even have people in their
party that have cavorted with ferracon
yeah it's like okay guys in your glass
houses on anti-semitism on the left are
you kidding you're gonna try to
bootstrap this into an issue where it's
totally non-existent
they were doing i guess stuff that was
illegal up there they're gonna be held
accountable they're jackasses
then he goes through not just talking
about the problems on the left with
anti-semitism then he reflect then he
reflected on and contrasted that with
his own record combating anti-semitism
in the state of florida
point after point after point
and then he concluded with this quote so
they tried to play games talking about
the democrats to try to politicize
why would they do that
why would they want to elevate half a
dozen male contents
and try to make this an issue for
political gain
very good question i think we all know
why it's gross
he responded to it
well why would you elevate these people
if not to try to pretend that there was
a nazi related controversy involving a
governor that you hate and you're scared
of
that's your answer right there
and it's not just some weirdos on
twitter in florida
it's comedy hosts on national television
who are not only unfunny in this
circumstance but just flat wrong which
is lazy to boot
they keep coming after him he keeps
responding
he knows how to fight back and that's
part of the reason why they fear him and
why we keep seeing this type of garbage
flung in his direction batted away
pretty effortlessly again by governor
desantis
we'll break will come back on the guy
benson show
you